protesters in the u.s state of idaho
gather outside a public health meeting
they say they oppose the mandatory
wearing of masks
some health officials say they face
similar demonstrations during the
coronavirus pandemic
if you haven't figured it out by now
this whole thing's a scam
but do not infringe on my rights to
choose not
to put one of those masks on tisha
coleman is the lynn county public health
administrator in the state of kansas
she says she's struggled to keep her
rural county safe from covert 19.
my friendship list has decreased
and i just i don't have
it's not that important to me to be
friends with someone who's going to be
so
against trying to protect the public
because they don't want to be told to do
something
at least 181 health workers in 38 states
have resigned
retired or have lost their jobs since
april experts say it's the largest
exodus of public health officials in
american history
this is a huge brain drain um in a field
where
experience and leadership particularly
right now
really matters linda vale is a health
officer in michigan
she's received letters at home calling
her a communist
and a fascist but she says she won't
resign
some clearly have made that decision and
they're not easy decisions to make
because this is not a job that you want
to leave during the midst of a pandemic
there's an entire community of people
that are out there
depending on you and with the biggest
vaccination campaign in the country's
history underway
that may be more true now than ever
before victoria gatenbee al jazeera